Speaker 1: The dangerous and unhinged CPAC
speech wasn't Trump's only public declaration
at CPAC in Washington, D.C. over the weekend.
He also gave a very strange press conference
during which he came out looking extraordinarily
pale, disheveled and even visibly confused.
He took a few questions, and there are just
a few moments here that I want to highlight
for you.
One of the topics that we've been talking
about recently is this loyalty pledge.
The Republican National Committee wants all
of the Republican candidates to sign a loyalty
pledge wherein they will say in exchange for
being allowed on the debate stage.
I will eventually support whoever is the Republican
nominee.
Now, we've been going back and forth.
Is that something that Trump would be willing
to agree to or not?
One side is no, of course he's not going to
agree to it.
The other side is sure he'll agree to it if
he needs to in order to get on the stage,
but then he won't abide by it.
Well, Trump was actually asked about the loyalty
pledge, and at least for now, he seems to
be saying, I don't know.
There's some people running that I wouldn't
be big on supporting.
So unclear whether that loyalty pledge is
something he's going to go for.
Let's take a listen.
Speaker 2: I'm happy about it.
Speaker 1: A lot of the people we talked to,
the.
Speaker 3: RNC who said they might have to
sign a loyalty pledge to participate in their
debates.
That's something you would do or.
Speaker 2: I don't know.
I mean, I'm just hearing about it for the
first time, about the loyalty last year, probably
people that I wouldn't be very happy about
endorsing in running.
So we'll see.
I think some of them I won't use names.
I don't want to insult anybody, but some of
them I would not be very happy about.
So I'll have to think about that.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So Trump saying fundamentally, and this is
an honest answer, right?
There are people running or potentially running
or likely running that he wouldn't actually
want to support.
So he's going to have to think about it now.
I still think that the truth is, when push
comes to shove, Trump, if he absolutely needs
to get on the debate stage, he will sign whatever
he will say, whatever he wants to be on the
debate stage.
And if that's going to prevent him, if not,
signing the loyalty pledge will keep him off
the debate stage.
He'll just sign it.
And then if it comes down to he loses the
nomination and then he wants to run as an
independent, he'll just ignore it all.
He'll say, you know, when I signed it, I didn't
assume they would rig it against me or whatever.
I still think that that is the most likely
thing.
These pledges, promises, they mean absolutely
nothing to Donald Trump.
At another moment, Donald Trump was asked
about some of the things that Mike Pompeo,
his own former secretary, one of his own former
secretaries of state, said during Pompeo's
own CPAC speech.
And Pompeo said, we don't need celebrity nominees.
And Trump was asked, Do you think Pompeo was
talking about you?
And Trump basically said, I don't see myself
as a celebrity, so probably not.
Speaker 2: Mike Pompeo Yesterday, we talked
about how the regime follows the networks
of leaders based on fragile egos and refused
to acknowledge reality.
Was he talking about the other ones?
No, I don't think he was talking about me.
I don't consider myself a celebrity leader.
I consider myself the leader of the country.
Speaker 1: How insane is.
Speaker 2: This into this film celebrity?
Maybe it helped me get elected.
Who knows?
But I don't consider that.
I consider myself a person that was president
for four years.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Trump doesn't consider himself a celebrity,
of course.
The reality is, were Trump not a celebrity
celebrity, he never would have become the
Republican nominee to begin with.
But okay, he can live in whatever fantasy
world he wants to live in.
And then lastly, the topic came up during
this press conference Trump gave.
Of if you are indicted, will you still run
for president?
And Trump said he would.
Here's like a little report on this from ABC.
Speaker 4: Trump himself faces multiple state
and federal criminal investigations and lawsuits,
but he told reporters none of them will force
him out of the race, even if he is indicted.
Speaker 2: So you'll stay in the race?
Oh, absolutely, I will.
Do you even think about leaving?
Speaker 4: While Trump dominated CPAC, Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis spoke this weekend at
the Reagan Library.
Speaker 1: Okay.
So Trump saying he would absolutely stay in
if he is indicted.
Now, I think that that statement is meaningless.
And what I mean by that is Trump has no choice
but to say he would stay in because if he
says, oh, no, no, no, if I'm indicted, I'm
leaving.
He immediately short circuits donations, he
short circuit support because there will be
people who will hear that and say, oh, wait
a second.
My going to support this guy or donate to
this guy.
If he bails, if he's indicted.
No.
So regardless of what the truth is, Trump
has to say he would stay in.
In reality, in practice, if Trump is indicted,
depending on what the charges are, depending
on what's going on, I think it will potentially
affect his race.
Now, whether he actually bails or whether
it just destroys his chances of winning are
two different scenarios which we can discuss
at some future point.
But I think Trump has no choice but to say
exactly this at this point in time, and we'll
see what the truth is if and when it happens.
And by the way, reports are that the indictment
may come down any time.
As I like to say, it could come down today
or never.
That's the range.
Anytime between today and never, Trump could
be indicted.